if you may let us know is your history
of playing chess on your birthday and
how did that possibly affect your
approach today or your mindset today in
today's game
um I would have of course love to have a
rest day at uh on the eve of my my
birthday so I could like have a at least
a token celebration
um apart from that I would say it's
pretty good I think I won at least one
game in the World Cup
um against almond I believe in 2005 and
obviously the match in 2016 was decided
on my birthday in the in the tie break
so it's going to take a lot to for me to
have bad Recollections of me playing on
my birthday even though I lost lost to
uh to uh so last year